[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CLAPPING]
EUGENE BREVDO: Hi.
So I'm Eugene.
I'm going to talk
about the sequence
models and the recurring neural
network API, Intensive Flow.
First, the motivating example.
Google Translate.
This is an awesome product.
A lot of people really love it.
And how does it work?
You type in or you speak in a
sentence in a source language,
some magic happens
in the background,
and you get the translation
in the target language.
And as of a couple of
months ago, the magic
got a little bit more magical.
And that's because
the product is now
backed by a neural
network, and specifically
a Sequence-to-Sequence Model.
So what is the
Sequence-to-Sequence Model?
Basically, it's two
recurring neural networks.
One on the left is the encoder.
And the encoder reads in one
word or word piece at a time,
from left to right.
Then it creates some
intermediate representation.
Then the decoder, which is
a second Recurring Neural
Network, or RNN, it receives
its start token that says,
start decoding in
this target language.
And it emits one
word or word piece
at a time in the
target language.
And once it admits
a token, it feeds
that back into
the next timestep,
and that token and
the previous state
are used to figure
out what to emit next.
Now in practice the model
is a little complicated.
You've seen this slide
a couple of times today.
And let me just
focus on the fact
that again here there's an
encoder RNN on the left,
there's some intermediate
representation in the middle,
and on the right we
have a decoder RNN.
And we're going to refer back
to the slide a couple of times.
But let's talk about what
we're going to talk about.
First of all, we'll
talk about how
to read and batch sequenced data
efficiently in a distributed
setting for training.
We'll talk about
the RNN API itself,
and as we talk about
that, we're going
to start talking about
family dynamic calculation
in TensorFlow and I'll
give you some tools that
allow you to do that.
Then we'll switch
tacks a little bit
and talk about how to trade
off flexibility for efficiency
in the RNN.
And finally, we'll talk
about a neat new library
that we're working
on that allows you
to perform dynamic decoding.
So reading and
batching sequence data.
So as we scale up our training
for Lexi the translation model,
it's very important to be able
to feed in large mini-batches
of variable-length data.
And so here we're
going to be focusing
on the source sentence,
which is on the lower left,
and on the target sentence,
which is on the lower right
and on the upper right.
And we're going to focus on
how to do this efficiently
in a distributed setting.
So for this we have a proto
called the sequence example.
And Google protobufs
are, as you've heard,
a language agnostic,
architecture agnostic,
data storage format.
And the sequence example
format is made specifically
to store variable-length
sequences.
So some of the pros, it
provides efficient storage
of multiple sequences
per example.
It supports a variable
number of features
per time stamp, which
we won't talk about
but is an important feature.
And also we provide
an efficient parser
that reads in a serialized
proto string and emits tensors
and/or sparse tensors,
according to the configuration
that you provide
And coming soon, well,
you've heard Noah talk
about TensorFlow Serving.
The sequence example
proto is going
to be a first-class citizen
in TensorFlow Serving.
So you'll be able to
use it for creating
data both at training
time and at serving time
with TensorFlow Serving.
So now that you can read
in sequence one at a time,
you need to be able to batch it.
And there are a couple
of ways to do this.
So one way is you basically
do the padding yourself.
So you pick a maximum
sequence length,
and each of your inputs, you
pad to that maximum sequence
length.
And then you pass it into the
standard TensorFlow batching
mechanism, the function
tf.training.batch.
So the major negatives
of this approach, one,
you need to know beforehand
the longest possible sequence
length.
And then you'll always pad
to that maximum length,
and as a result, you're
wasting both space and time
during training.
So can we do better?
So the next best thing is to
allow the batching mechanism
to perform the padding for you.
So you get your variable
length sequences one at a time,
and you feed them into
the special padding queue.
And the queue, when it
reads off the mini-batch,
it finds the longest
sequence, and it
pads all the other sequences
up to that maximum length.
So this is a little bit better.
You don't need to know
the maximum length.
When you get a mini-batch,
you're no longer
wasting space or time,
because you're only
padding up to the maximum
length within that batch.
However, as you're trying to
scale up training, for example,
and your batch sizes become
larger and larger, 32, 64, 128,
you're more and more
likely that at least one
of the elements in every
mini-batch is going to be long.
And so as a result,
you're back to where
you started in the
previous slide,
wasting space and
computation time.
But we can do better.
So the solution here
is to actually create
a number of different queues,
which we called buckets,
running at the same time.
And when you pass
into this mechanism
a variable-length
sequence, it will put it
into one of a number of queues.
And each queue will
contain only sequences
that are about the same length.
And when a mini-batch is
available from that queue,
that mini-batch is returned
to you as the next mini-batch.
And all of the sequences
within that mini-batch
are about the same length.
There's a little bit of padding.
But this still gives you
the best of both worlds,
because every
mini-batch everything
is about the same length.
You're not padding too much.
You're not wasting too much
computation time or space
during training.
And most of the time, you get
your short or medium-length
sequences as they
come in, almost as
quickly as they come in.
Every once in a while
you'll get a mini-batch
from your spill-over from
the very long sequences.
But again, even though it
takes longer to compute
and uses more
memory, at least all
of the sequences within this
mini-batch are all pretty long,
so you're not wasting time.
And we have a function for that.
And it's called
Bucket-by-Sequence Length.
Finally, for those
of you who are not
necessarily interested in
Sequence-to-Sequence Models,
but are interested in
building language models
or variational auto
encoders, for example,
we have a State
Saver, which allows
you to implement
something called Truncated
Backpropogation Through Time.
So what this means is that you
pick a fixed number of times,
steps that you unroll
for, and any sequence
which is longer that than
that number of time steps,
get split up into
multiple segments.
When you finish your mini-batch,
any sequences or segments which
are not the completed sequence,
the state is saved for you.
Some bookkeeping is
done in the background,
and at the next
training iteration,
that state is loaded.
And you continue processing that
sequence with that Saved State.
And we have a function
for that, it's
called
batch_sequences_with_states.
So now that we've talked
a little bit about how
to efficiently read in
variable-length data and batch
it, let's talk about RNN's.
So just to get everybody on
the same page, what is an RNN?
An RNN is basically
a unit of computation
that you repeat over and over.
It's essentially a for loop.
And the way that the
forward calculation flows,
you get inputs from below.
So X at every timestep.
And you have some inputs
which are the previous state
from the previous timestep.
So these are the
arrows from the left.
And this intermediate
calculation
emits a new output, H,
and an updated state
for the next timestep.
So this diagram specifically,
is an implementation of LSTM,
or Long Short Term Memory,
which is a very popular RNN
architecture.
So as I said, you can
think of it as a for loop.
And in fact, you can
implement it, say in Python,
as a for loop.
So let's go through this
relatively straightforward
approach.
So you have a function RNN.
It accepts a function cell
that reads in inputs in state
and emits new outputs in state.
You also provide it with
a list of input tensors,
and you provide it with
some initial state.
So you set your state
to the initial state.
You loop over your
list of input tensors,
so these are dense
floating point tensors.
And at each iteration,
you call cell.
You emit an output
and a new state.
You append this output to
your list of output tensors.
And at the very end you return
this list and the final state.
So as I showed you on
the previous slide,
you have for an LSTM, for
example, the state is actually
two tensors, not just one.
For a [? GRE, ?] which is
another popular architecture,
there's only one
tensor for this state.
And so one of the problems
is that the cell function
and the initial
state are coupled,
so you need to provide
an initial state that
says one or a couple of tensors,
which usually have all zero
values.
And if you want to
change your architecture
and try another one, so
you change your cell,
you need to be able
to easily generate,
for example, a new initial state
with a different structure.
So that problem is
actually fairly easy
to solve by changing the
functions to objects,
and I'll talk about that next.
The harder problem
is that here you
have a list of input tensors.
And this is a fixed size list,
you're in Python after all.
And you're building
a graph that has
a fixed number of timesteps.
And so as a result,
you're basically
losing the ability to run a
variable number of iterations.
We'll talk about that next.
So first, the RNN cell.
So the RNN cell is a base
class that we provide,
which a different architecture
subclass, and it provides
helper properties that
give you knowledge
about that architecture.
Now, the second important
feature of the RNN cell,
class library, is that you can
treat each timestep as building
a timestep as building a layer.
And so you've heard
Francois talk about Keras.
And for the last month
or so in the background,
we've been working to make RNN
cells act like Keras layers.
And so eventually we hope
to have full compatibility
between the two.
But let's go through an example.
Suppose you want to
implement an LSTM.
First, you build and
a basic LSTM class.
It's a subclass of RNN cell.
It has two important properties.
The first one is state size.
And what this state
size tells you
is that my state is
composed of two tensors.
And each tensor has
num units columns,
so these are the
depth of the LSTM.
The second property,
output size,
tells you I emit at every
timestep a single tensor
and has num units columns.
Finally, there is
a call method that
accepts an impotensor and a
state tuple, in this case,
and decomposes the
state into two tensors,
performs intermediate
calculations for the timestep,
and emits and new output, a
new H, and then you stay tuple.
So this a fairly
flexible framework.
And we have a fairly
sizable library
of different implementations
of different architectures,
including basic RNN
cells, LSTM GRU,
a bunch of other interesting
research oriented
architectures.
One that's particularly
interesting
is the bottom one, NASL.
So if you heard Megan
talk this morning
about neural
architecture search,
one of the fruits of
this research program
is this new architecture
that was basically
learned by
reinforcement learning
on different possible
RNN architectures.
And so we have an implementation
of that, as of this week,
on TensorFlow GitHub.
It's called NASL.
So check it out see
if it provides you
with the performance
quality boost.
And within Google,
we have dozens
of slightly different
or radically different
RNN architectures that are
used by different teams
to solve their problem.
So we've talked about
solving the simple problem.
Let's talk about how to
perform dynamic calculation
in TensorFlow.
And there are
basically two tools
that I like to talk
about, and these
are the main primitives
that are used
to build dynamic calculations.
The first one is
the tf.while_loop,
and it allows you to build
dynamic loops and supports
backdrop.
The second one is
called TensorArray.
And this is required to be able
to efficiently read and write
slices of tensors and
also supports backprop.
So the while_loop was
developed by Yuan,
who is a research scientist
on the brain team.
And it's a function
that basically
accepts three arguments--
the cond, lambda, the body
lambda, and loop_vars.
So the cond is the condition
function that tells you,
should I continue
this loop or not?
The body implements the actual
computation per timestep.
And the loop_vars are
the initial conditions
being fed to the while_loop.
So let's go through an example.
We'll start with
a tuple of tuples.
ijk_0.
The values it takes on
are zero, one and two.
The condition lambda looks
at the first component i,
and says, continue looping
while i is less than 10.
The body takes both of
these parameters, variables
i and j, k, increments
i by 1, and updates
jk with the calculation
that you see there.
You pass these into the
while_loop, and at the output,
you receive a tuple
of tuples of tensors.
So the final value of i,
which if you look at this,
basically is going
to be equal to 10.
And jk_final, which is a
tuple of tensors, which
contains the result
of performing
the calculation there 10 times.
So while_loop gets you
almost all the way there,
but if you need to be able
to process slices of tensors
at every timestep, you need to
be able to efficiently access
them and to write new ones.
So this we have a tensorarray.
So let's suppose that you have
a matrix and you don't know
at [? graft ?] build time how
many rows that matrix has.
But you can use the
TensorFlow primitive tf.shape
to access that at runtime.
So let's say this is equivalent
to an unknown sequence
length in your mini-batch.
So first you create
a tensorarray,
whose number of entries at
size is equal to matrix_rows,
and then you can unpack
or unstack the matrix
into that tensorarray.
Then inside the
while_loop body, you
can access any index that you
want and you'll get back out
of vector.
You perform some
processing, and then you
need to take the result and
store that in the new matrix.
So the way you do that is
first you create a tensorarray.
Again, in this case, you know
the size that it's going to be,
but in fact, you don't even need
to know the size before hand.
Then within the loop,
you write an update
that tensorarray at
whatever row you want.
And the results of your
calculation [INAUDIBLE]
vector, you pass it in there.
You take that tensor
you update it.
At the very end
of the while_loop,
you get the finally
updated tensorarray.
And then you can stack it, pack
it, and you get a new matrix.
And that's the result of
your of your calculation.
Between these two primitives,
you can get pretty far.
In fact, we have a whole library
of functional building blocks
in TensorFlow that you
can use based on these.
So we have a mao function.
We have TensorFlow
scan, which is
somewhat similar to theano scan,
in some ways more powerful.
We have the leftfold
and rightfold operators.
We have the dynamic
RNN function,
which I'll talk about next.
We have a couple of
other variants of RNN.
And also we have a
dynamic decoder function,
which I'll also talk about
towards the end of this talk.
Finally, there are a bunch of
other interesting algorithms
that you can implement
using these primitives.
So let's talk about the encoder
of the translation model.
So a couple of
interesting things
that we can see in this encoder.
First of all, it has
eight stacked LSTM layers.
And each one sits on a
different GPU device,
and between each of the layers
there are residual connections.
So residual connections
are actually
very important in being able to
train a performant model that
has such a large
stack of layers.
So we'd like to
implement this by using
the API I presented to you.
Turns out, it's two lines
of code, fairly gnarly code,
but let me [INAUDIBLE]
you through them.
So first of all, you
build your LSTM cells,
each one has, say, depth of 512.
You then would like to
add residual connections,
so you wrap each
of these objects
in the residual wrapper.
You'd like to put each of these
layers on a different GPU,
so you wrap that in
a device wrapper,
and each one goes on
GPU0 GPU1, and so on.
So you make a list
of these, and then
you wrap that in
a multi RNN cell.
So you take this
object and you pass it
to the dynamic RNN function.
It takes the cell.
It takes a tensor of
mini-batches of inputs.
It takes a vector with
the sequence lengths
of each of the
mini-batch entries,
and a couple of
other arguments that
control the trade between memory
consumption and performance.
So what I presented
to you so far
is a fairly flexible
API for customizing
implementing your
own RNN architectures
and dynamic decoding.
And sometimes you know that
you want to use an LSTM,
or you want to use a GRU, you
want to use an established RNN
architecture.
So in these cases,
you have the option
to trade off flexibility
for performance.
And in TensorFlow, basically, we
provide three ways to do that.
The first one Chris and Todd
talked about earlier today
is XLA.
I'll talk about that one first.
There are also handwritten C++
kernels that provide manually
fused implementations of,
say, LSTM, per timestep.
And they're also
manually designed,
fully fused RNN
implementation that fuse
the entire calculation
across time.
So as you look at these, think
about the kinds of trade-offs
that you're making.
So you're trading off
flexibility for speed.
Some of these implementations
don't work well
on some architectures but
are faster are on others.
And I'll mention these.
So let's first talk about XLA.
The nice thing about XLA is
that there's very minimal
flexibility trade-off.
You implement an RNN cell
and you get an architecture
that you care about.
And then it's basically one
step to get it compiled.
So if before you had a stack
of eight LSTM stem cells
and you want to fuse each of
them individually per layer,
you simply wrap that
LSTM cell in something
called a compiled wrapper,
which we recently released.
And this basically performs
that builds [INAUDIBLE]
compilation for you per layer.
Alternatively, if you want
to be a bit more aggressive
and try to fuse
across all layers,
you basically move the
compilation outside
of the multi-RNN cell.
So pretty easy to
use and flexible.
When is this a good idea?
So when should you use XLA?
You saw some slides about
that in previous talks.
I also ran a couple
of benchmarks
myself training a multi-RNN
cell with three separately fused
LSTM layers running
for 50 timesteps.
And I tried this on slightly
different architectures
of different architecture sizes.
So what are the takeaways?
First of all, if you're
doing this on a GPU--
say I had a Tesla
K40 available--
and you're using a small
batch size and a small depth
for yourselves, today it's kind
of a toss-up of whether it's
actually faster.
The XLA team is actually
investigating this area,
and hopefully the
performance will
be sped up for this regime.
In more realistic
training cases where
you have large
batch size, 16, 32,
and so on, even with
a small cell depth
or with larger cell depths,
as you increase the numbers,
your performance on a
GPU is going to improve.
15%, 30%, 45%.
And again, this is an area
under active development,
so it's going to
continue to improve.
Now with CPU, there's
currently not much benefit.
So don't use XLA there.
Now if you're
interested in ahead
of time compilation for
an embedded device--
say, an Android
device or iOS device--
today it's not
faster to use XLA,
but there are other benefits.
There is a reduction in
memory usage by the model.
A reduction in the binary size.
And again, while I didn't
benchmark these aspects of it,
this is something worth
doing as you're looking
into building embedded models.
So my current
recommendation, try XLA.
Benchmark your
intended use case.
The benchmarks are
actually open source
and they're in GitHub repo,
so you can look at them
and use them to compare the
runtimes and the memory usage
yourself.
Moving on from XLA, we have
some handwritten C++ kernels
for the LSTM and GRU
cells per timestep.
And these work on
CPU's and on GPU's.
They tend to be faster
for smaller batch sizes
and on mobile devices.
So try them out.
If you're interested in
fully fused calculations,
especially on mobile
devices, the LSTM block
fused cell is even
faster for these cases.
So look at that.
Now, if you're working,
you have nvidia GPUs,
you're using CUDNN,
we have CUDNN wrappers
that allow you to speed
up your training up
to three times, which
is awesome if you're
working on these devices.
And it's fairly flexible.
Supports bi-directional
RNNs, stacked RNNs for LSTM,
GRU, and a couple of
other architectures.
And as of about a month ago,
you can take the parameters
that these layers use,
and during export time,
convert them from the
custom CUDNN format
to canonical format, so that you
can then take these checkpoints
and load them in a
different graph that
uses one of the other
LSTM implementations.
What that means is that
you can train on GPU
and then perform
inference on a CPU
or on a mobile device,
which is pretty cool.
So we've talked about that.
Let's look at this neat new
API that we're working on
for dynamic decoding.
And in fact,
decoding tends to be
the most complicated part
of many Sequence-to-Sequence
Models.
And that's partly because you
have to attend to the encoder
output.
And partly because you're
emitting an example
at every timestep, and then
you're feeding that back in.
And decoder has to
decide when to stop.
So we have this library.
It's a new object-oriented API.
It's under active development.
We hope to release a new neuro
machine translation tutorial,
which uses this library.
And the code is already in
TensorFlow GitHub master branch
in the t.f.contrib.seq2seq
package.
The main goal of the decoder
is to make a plug-and-play
and batch-friendly decoding
library that allows you
to first pick a sampling method,
pick the RNN architecture,
then pick, if you want to have
a fancy decoding approach-- say,
using attention or an
in-graph beam search--
and then decode.
So let's start by first
picking a sampling method.
So during decoding,
when you're training,
oftentimes you want to just use
the Ground Truth as your inputs
at every timestep.
So in this case,
we have a helper
called the training helper.
And you feed it the [? tensor ?]
decoder inputs and the sequence
lengths, and that's
all you need to do.
However, if you want to try
something a bit more fancy--
let's say you want to
use scheduled sampling,
another popular approach
for training decoders.
So use another helper.
In addition to the Ground
Truth decoder inputs,
you can also say, well, the
RNN is going to emit an output.
I'll treat that as logits.
And I'm going to sample from
these and get a sample ID.
And I'll look up in
an embedding table
and feed that in
as the next input.
So here you have to provide
the embeddings, as well
as the probability
with which you're
going to choose whether you use
Ground Truth or you're going
to sample.
Finally, at inference time,
you don't have Ground Truth,
but you do have your
embeddings and what
you can do is you can read
the outputs of the RNN,
feed them as logits.
And take the arg max,
the highest probability
output in your vocabulary, and
look that up in the embeddings,
and feed that as
your next input.
So you pick one of these.
Then you pick your
RNN architecture.
And in this case, it's
the same architecture
as we had for the encoder.
And then you build your decoder.
So this is an object that
combines the cell architecture
and the helper object,
the sampling approach,
and possibly also
provides an initial state.
Now, the simplest one
doesn't do anything extra.
However, this week
and next week,
we're actually
working on releasing
an attentional decoder, where
you provide an attention
mechanism that
describes how you,
at every timestep
same translation,
you look at the output
of the encoder and say,
oh, maybe I should be attending
to this part of the input
sentence, and that
will help me to decide
what word to emit next.
So finally, you
have your decoder.
Just decode, call
dynamic decode on it.
This will return to you the
output, the dynamic decoder
output, the tensor, and
the final decoder state.
So the outputs, for a simple
decoder, there are two.
One is the tensor of the RNN
outputs at every time stamp.
And the second one, is a
tensor with sample IDs.
So if you chose a
sampling decoder,
this will emit the
actual categories,
the actual words that were
chosen at every timestep.
And in this case, for the final
decoder state, because you
have a stack of
eight LSTMs, it's
going to be a list of
eight tuples containing
the LSTM and states.
So to combine everything,
essentially four lines of code,
first you choose
your sampling method.
Then you choose your
RNN architecture,
you build your decoder,
and then you decode.
So we hope that
this is something
that will take a fairly
complicated procedure
and make it as simple
and flexible as possible.
So to summarize, I've talked
about a flexible sequence input
pipeline that allows you
to scale up distributed
training of sequence models.
I've talked about the
RNN API in TensorFlow.
It has hundreds of
uses within Google
and many, many users
outside of Google as well.
I've talked about
dynamic calculations
within TensorFlow
and dynamic RNNs.
These have a reduced
memory footprint compared
to the basic for loop approach.
They allow cast
your GPU activations
to the CPU reducing
the memory usage.
And they're essentially as fast
as the equivalent for loop.
I've also talked
about how to improve
the performance of your
RNNs by a fusion and some
of the trade-offs
that you make there.
And finally, I've introduced
a new decoder library
that we hope you'll
all check out and try.
It's available on GitHub now.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]